how much did the the controversy around
that film i guess specifically that
scene
affect your your sort of uh i mean
because it really brought a lot of
attention obviously
more attention to you i mean how did
that affect your career
you mean that scene but a lot more
dedicated
the script in the script um
the the the previous scene before
that scene was the scene where michael
and and
went to went to the stinson beach house
right and then
and then she was arrested and they were
gonna bring her into requesting
in that scene um the the
the in the script the
michael saw that she wasn't wearing
underwear
right um the
the interrogation scene
um where the whole world saw
that she wasn't wearing underwear was
paul's notion
um the the uh
and then and of course it was a
revolutionary
scene in the history of bill um
the but the script didn't do that in the
previous
so when i first saw the finished product
with my now growing son
steve he was about 17. um
we were in marin county theater and we
walked out
and steve said
my god how did you write that
scene that was just an amazing scene
and you know you have cathartic moments
with children
and i had a choice i could either lie to
and tell the truth
it wasn't in my script i know how much
you love it and i know
people are going to go crazy but i
didn't write it
and then he said you mean the director
wrote it on this
like death to me
and i said well yes he did he did right
um and now
having said that i think it was it was
brilliant to bolt
to do it that way yeah um the um
and then it became i deny
that that's the reason the movie was hit
because
because i think that that it was it's a
terrific thriller
and i thought sharon was wonderful of it
um
and really wonderful because
juxtaposition between
the innocence and and and the and and
the lethal nature of what she was
i think she did it beautifully and then
and not to underrate michael
it was the rock in the movie maybe the
movie was really based on
the right thing so um but
you know i mean it's a complicated
question you like to
ask complicated questions and in some
ways
you know i'm i'm i'm
really sorry that i didn't write the
damn scene
you